good morning John it's Tuesday Tuesday
what am i doing let's just say we had a
brotherly conversation in which you were
like hey I want to make a project for
awesome video this week and I doesn't
make a lot of sense for me to do it on
Tuesday when the project for awesome
isn't until the weekend I'm taking you
to stivity you take my Friday video
everything worked out better than
expected John you know how the ipcc just
came out with its climate change report
it was full of bad I have people asked
me pretty regularly how I as a person
who knows a fair bit about the situation
we are putting ourselves into have any
hope at all left this is terrible
because I honest I don't think that you
can do anything without hope so it's bad
and I think that it is a symptom of a
few different things one news is gonna
focus on bad news we've talked about
that plenty on this channel and in this
culture I don't think that we need to
talk about it much more than just
needing to mention it number to some
people and I understand this might hype
it up a little bit because when you have
been doing this for so long and no one
is paying attention you start to pitch
the scariest version of the story and
and you can tell that story and it isn't
the lie like yes the world is going to
be worse there's gonna be climate
refugees probably the whole global
situation will destabilize a little bit
as we deal with this problem I also am
desperate to have people pay attention I
just don't think that that ultimately
works it might get you attention without
action the third thing is that we're bad
at non-binary things like very bad is
not the apocalypse we have lived all of
human history as a species so far
somewhere in-between utopia and
apocalypse like we've been there that's
the only place we've ever been oh you
often hear about tipping points like
there are a lot of different tipping
points that we're gonna deal with but
ultimately there's always going to be a
spectrum of bad and our future is gonna
be somewhere on that spectrum the place
where I'm at with regard to climate
change which is something I know more
about than most of the big problems
we're dealing with has actually helped
me have more hope for those other
problems there just is not a binary
state of fixed or broken when it comes
to climate change just like there isn't
when it comes to crime or justice where
racism or suffer there are billions of
variables and we all get to affect the
variables as we individually move
through light and one of the recipes
I've seen work for other people and for
myself more like the pie and ice cream
of activism is care mixed with ho
witnessing people who I have seen who
are full of hope and full of care that
is what gets me up off my butt to
actually do something I personally don't
have too much problem with the care part
of this but I have at various times in
my life lost a grip on the home but we
are not working toward a fixed state we
are working toward a better place on the
spectrum of bad this isn't about success
or failure it's about every little bit
of good work adding up to a better world
and at no time of the year do I feel
that more than during the project for
awesome the campaign on IndieGoGo just
launched its digital perks there's
physical perks exclusive podcasts you
can get signed pieces of my manuscript
that has editing marks from when I was
fixing it up I just found 10 episodes of
hankgames and games with Haake on old
hard drives and I've uploaded them to
the hankgames vault is another challenge
coin to add to my collection John the
project for awesome for me is full of
hope and care and that's why it feels
good because it's doing good both
because of and in spite of all the doom
and gloom maybe that might feel false
but I don't think it is I actually think
that that is how almost all of the great
work of humanity has been done not out
of despair but out of hope join us for
the live stream during which we will be
playing games and having great guests
and I'm gonna do my punishment live and
record it in an edit it for next week
upload your project for awesome videos
I've put some resources if you're making
one of those in the description and also
you can get a project for awesome calm
to learn more John I'll see you on
Friday